The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, we've
got some good competition here.
So let's actually
work through it.
So I have a function
called always sunny
and it's going to take in two
variables right, t1 and t2.
And I'm calling it
with cloudy and cold.
So when I do my
function call, t1
is going to be equal to cloudy.
These are strings
but I'm not going
to bother putting the quotes.
And t2 is equal to cold comma.
So remember what I said,
with a comma it's a tuple,
without a comma it's a string.
So t1 is actually
going to be a string.
And t2 is actually a tuple.
OK.
So that's the first sort
of trick to this question.
So I've made my function call
and I've assigned t1 and t2
to be those two values.
So the next line is sun is
equal to sunny comma sun.
So sun is going to be
this tuple of two strings.
The next line is figuring
out what first is.
So first is going to be-- so
I'm looking at my t1 here,
it's a string.
The fact that I have
parentheses doesn't actually
make a difference when
I'm talking about strings.
Like that.
So when I'm indexing into
a string, t1 at position 0
actually just gives
me a C because it's
a string not a tuple.
And t2 up position zero
says, OK well, this
is a tuple that contains
only one element.
That element being
at position 0,
and that element is
the string, cold.
So this is a tuple.
So I'm taking everything
right before the first comma.
And that happens to be just the
one element that's in there.
So this is just
the string C cold.
And then I'm returning
here a tuple.
And the tuple I'm returning
is sun at position 0,
so that's just sunny comma.
Just doing what's in here.
And then first, and first
was this string, C cold.
So really the important
thing about this example
was to make sure
that you understand
the difference between what a
string is and what a tuple is.